>> Poets coming through.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Carla Hayden: Good
afternoon, I'm Hayden,
the Librarian of Congress.
And I am truly delighted
to welcome you
to the Appointment Ceremony
for the Seventh Class
of the National Student Poets.
And you may clap
right now, again.
[ Applause ]
Now I have to take this
opportunity to welcome those
in the hometowns of our
National Student Poets
who are watching the
livestream of this event.
Thank you to our
livestream partners,
and I feel like I should wave.
Cabell County Public Library
in Huntington, West Virginia.
[ Applause ]
Linn-Henley Research Library
in Birmingham, Alabama.
[ Applause ]
Fletcher Free Library
in Burlington, Vermont.
[ Applause ]
The Mesa Main Library
and Red Mountain Library
in Mesa, Arizona.
[ Applause ]
And the Las Vegas
Springs Preserve
and Las Vegas Academy,
in Las Vegas, Nevada.
[ Applause ]
Now I have to also tell you that
I was very pleased and honored
to hold a pinning ceremony
for these talented young poets
in my office area just
less than an hour ago.
And it's the second time
that we've been able
to have that honor.
And I have to say it is one
of the highlights of the year.
We also have two poets from
the previous year with us today
and we're delighted
to see them as well.
Now at the pinning, and the
pinning, really you have
to see the beautiful pins.
At the pinning, I was
joined by Kit Matthew,
Director of the Institute
of Museum
and Library Services, Kit.
[ Applause ]
Virginia McEnerney, Executive
Director of the Alliance
for Young Artists and Writers.
[ Applause ]
And you'll hear more from
both of them in a minute.
But let me just say how much
I appreciate their stewardship
of the National Poet -- Poets
Program, and their commitment
to our next generation of poets.
Now you'll also year
from two very,
very special guests
this afternoon.
Noted columnist,
Mr. David Brooks.
[ Applause ]
And singer songwriter,
Valerie June.
[ Applause ]
In addition to being
powerful voices,
both of our special guests have
found inspiration at the Library
of Congress, our
nation's library.
Mr. Brooks has written
about the power
of the Thomas Jefferson
Building,
right across the street.
And it was there that
Valerie June immersed herself
in the American Folk Life
Center's Historic Recording.
So we are very proud that you
have found our collections
to be so useful to you.
Darius, Daniel, Alexandra,
Heather Laurel Jensen,
and Ariana.
I hope you are equally inspired
by beginning your National
Student Poet Term here
at the Library of Congress.
And we are very proud that
you, and I'm telling you
from previous poets, will always
have that connection to us.
As I told you at the
pinning, and you presented me
with autographed copies, you
all should be very jealous.
I have my own autographed
copies.
Maybe after the ceremony
you will get your programs
autographed too.
Don't forget us as
you become famous.
[ Laughter ]
You are famous now.
Now there is another remarkable
poet connected to the Library
who is excited to
be part of this day.
And right now she's
flying back from Alaska
where she kicked off
her second term project,
American Conversations:
Celebrating Poetry
in Rural Communities.
But before she left,
she recorded a special
message for you.
He's trying to get sound
and I want it noted
that I am not doing any of this.
[ Laughter ]
It makes me feel so good
when someone else has
these technology issues,
and they're younger than I am.
[ Laughter ]
Dora how old are you?
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
And I'm so tempted
to try to help.
But that will not do.
There was opening music.
It's Tracy Smith,
the Poet Laureate,
and she is in her second
year, and she wanted
to emphasize using poetry in
specifically rural communities.
[ Music ]
[ Laughter ]
So what we're going to do,
and I wish I had like one iota
of her talent, because I
could actually read some
of her poetry and tell you.
And so you see her, and
she wanted to do this.
[ Laughter ]
And we will make sure that
this is available shortly,
because I had the
opportunity to talk Tracy
and asked her to,
to record this.
Because she believes in the
healing power of poetry.
And when she was selected as
the Poet Laureate it was one
of my first opportunities to
be involved with the program.
She said she wanted
to go to communities
that had needed other ways
to talk about difficult
and challenging issues.
And so in rural areas,
Native American communities.
>> Tracy Smith: And I feel
like we actually have
something meaningful to say --
[ Applause ]
.
Soon to be a poet or a trade.
I'm sorry I'm not
there with you tonight.
I'm actually in Alaska talking
poetry with new friends.
But I'm excited to
join you tomorrow
and celebrate your
accomplishments.
[ Music ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Dr. Carla Hayden:
We wanted sound.
And we've got it.
So we'll make sure though
that you get to see all
of our message, because
basically that's what she's
hoping that you young poets
will realize, that your words,
and your way with words, have
a way of reaching out to others
that might not have their
own way of expressing things.
And that's what she
wanted to wish for you,
because she's found
that in her career.
And she's taking
it in another year
to communities throughout
this country,
that need the healing
power of words.
So I hope you will enjoy
meeting her tomorrow.
Her flight is on
schedule, she will be here.
And now I'm going to bring up
Kit to continue the program.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Katheryn Matthew: Well
that video will be a treat.
Thank you Carla, we appreciate
your work as both a librarian
and former member of
the National Museum
and Library Services Board.
We, at IMLS, our
acronym, welcome to D.C.
if you don't know
the land of acronyms.
Always enjoy working with
our colleagues at the Library
of Congress on the
National Book Festival
which is coming up this weekend.
So I hope many of you
will partake of that.
I'm really delighted to
be with you all today
to celebrate this 2018 Class
of the National Student
Poets Program.
We are extremely proud to have
partnered with the Alliance
for Young Artists and Writers
to establish the program
which shares exemplary
work from teen poets
like those we honor today,
with a national audience.
As you well know, IMLS
also supports libraries
and museums large and
small across the country
as they enhance many
forms of literacy
and artistic expression,
including this poetry program.
Writing and libraries of
course, are always intertwined
as I was reminded of this
last week when up in Maine.
I had been telling
my Maine friends
about upcoming activities
at IMLS.
I can't turn off my brain
about libraries and museums.
Including this Poetry
Celebration.
The next day my friend
was driving me on one
of those endless
winding Maine roads.
My friend suddenly turned
the Jeep of the road,
through a battered chain link
fence into a small cemetery.
The grass was try, scruffy
and there were few
graveside decorations.
It seemed utilitarian
and in fact ignored.
At the very back edge
of the cemetery was a very
non-descript plot under a tree.
Elwin Brooks White.
Various votives,
rocks, paper sculptures,
folded notes were perched
on the simple headstone.
Many of White's books
and artworks were donated
to the nearby Friend Memorial
Library in Brooklyn, Maine.
One book inscription reads
for the Friend Memorial
Public Library
from a long-time
admirer E.B. White.
And in a letter addressed
to the children of Troy,
Michigan congratulating them
upon their newly opened public
library, E.B. White
wrote, Books hold many
of the secrets of the world.
Books are people.
People who have managed
to stay alive by hiding
between the covers of a book.
And we can say the same of
poetry as White did of books.
Poetry holds many of the
secrets of the world,
and people stay alive
within and through poetry.
Many libraries and museums
across our nation are
critical platforms
for community expression
and advancing literacy
and learning for all Americans.
And the National Student Poets
Program leverages these shared
community spaces to
create new perspectives,
connect us across
generations, and spark critical
and essential conversations.
This year's five exceptional
student writers, Darius, Daniel,
Alexandra, Heather and
Ariana were selected by some
of our nation's finest literary
voices and leaders in education.
And they rose to the top of more
than 300 national medalists.
That's a feat.
In the scholastic art
and writing awards.
They will receive academic
awards, opportunities
to showcase their work in
libraries, museums, schools
and at festivals and
events across America.
And they'll serve as
regional literary ambassadors
for the coming year.
Each student poet from this
year's class is charged
with designing a special
community service project
which may include readings,
workshops, webinars,
classroom visit's,
interviews and conversations
with established poets.
In previous years young
writers have chosen
to focus their efforts on
outreach and engagement
with military families,
Alzheimer's patients,
English as second language
students, homeless youth
and Native American students.
And I really look forward
to hearing how each
of you will reach out to others.
This is just the beginning.
Whether reading E.B. White or
participating in a poetry slam,
I truly believe anyone
can own the power
of poetry and have a voice.
Our five winning poets are
ambassadors for poetry's power
to inspire curiosity, learning
confidence and connections.
I want to congratulate you
on your accomplishments,
and we look forward to your
continued service throughout the
next year.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Virginia McEnerney:
Good afternoon.
Welcome. I'm Virginia McEnerney.
I'm the Executive Director of
the Alliance for Young Artists
and Writers, the
national nonprofit
that presents the Scholastic
Art and Writing awards.
We are so honored to
be partnered with IMLS
in presenting this wonderful
program and bringing young poets
to museums and libraries
across the country.
And I really want to thank
the Library of Congress
for once again, so graciously
hosting us at this event.
We have some special guests
here in the audience tonight.
And I would be remiss if
I didn't start by thanking
and honoring Olivia Morgan,
who's the head of the --
who started the program.
Where's Olivia?
Thank you Olivia.
So glad that you're here.
[ Applause ]
The inspiration behind
the program.
I also want to welcome
Dr. Lucianne Walkowicz,
whose notable in the back
by her stunning hairstyle.
Lucianne is here because
she's a proud alumnus
of the Scholastic Art
and Writing award.
She's also the Chair
of the Astro Biology --
she holds the Chair
in Astro Biology here
at the Library of Congress.
She'll be our Alumni Honoree in
the Scholastic Awards this year,
and Dr. Walkowicz told
me that she included
on her post doc fellowship
application to Princeton,
the scholastic award for
painting that she won
in tenth grade, because it gave
her the idea that she could be
who she wanted to be and
express herself artfully
about Astro Biology.
I also want to acknowledge
and thank my friends
from the Poetry Coalition under
the leadership of Jen Benka
at the Academy of American
Poets, and our pals
in the Poetry Foundation.
It's so great of
you to come here
and launch these young poets
onto their year of service.
As Kit mentioned, these
fine poets became eligible
to be appointed as
national student poets
because they first
received national awards
through the Scholastic
Art and Writing Awards.
The awards were started in 1923,
which is just about the time
that the word teenager first
appeared in the dictionary.
And our mission and
our purpose is
to encourage creative
young people.
So we have the privilege
of launching these creative
young people onto their year
of service and I wish all
of you could get to see some
of them at work as I, I do.
Last year on went on tour in
Idaho with Kinsell Houston
who worked in a number
of different settings.
She did a poetry
workshop for Doosan's,
at the Boise Art Museum.
She worked on an air
force base high school,
and then she spent her
day at Boise High School
where she read some
of her own work
and advocates a creative
word cloud,
and then write poems
about their homes.
And when it came time to share,
one of the students
raised their hand.
And she was 15 years old.
And started reading, I
remember my first home.
And then you went -- she went
on to artfully describe seven
more homes adding details
about the light, the step
families that had come and gone.
It was a stunning
moment, a pause.
The class did this.
[ Snapping fingers ]
We do a lot of this
in the Scholastic Art
and Writing Awards.
And they moved on,
but I've reflected
on that student quite a bit.
Because she so aptly described
how poetry shortcuts the
expression of complex
emotions and ideas.
And how powerful it is, it
has the power to connect us,
to explain, to provoke,
to express, to explore.
It's very complicated being
a teenager these days.
It always has been,
but especially now.
What better past time could they
possibly grab on to than poetry
and helping guide them
through the teenage years.
These teen poets are
particularly well suited
to advocate.
They're young enough to be
relatable to little kids.
And they're mature enough for
adults to take them seriously.
The 2018 Class of National
Student Poets joins a legacy
of incredible young writers
who feel poetry in their bones.
And their voices are
strong and unique,
and they will enter their year
of service fully committed
to sharing their voices insights
and artistry to audiences large
and small, grand and not so
grand, like those at the Library
of Congress, and like
those at Boise High School.
Poetry is an ancient
artform that continues
to reinvent itself, and
make itself newly relevant,
generation after generation.
We are so proud to be here
to introduce you today
to this generation's
finest young poets.
So we have some wonderful
guests joining us here today.
I want to thank all of you and
it's my honor now to welcome
to the podium, New York Times
Op Ed Columnist David Brooks.
There you go.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> David Brooks: So I was
talking to the students,
the poets, earlier and
I mentioned when I was
in college I applied for a --
to -- for a short story class.
The professor thought it was
short story and poetry and so
to get into the class we had
to write a short story
and then also a poem.
And I had never written
a poem before in my life.
So I wrote the story
and I wrote the poem,
and I wrote in the bottom,
I make no claims on poetry.
And my professor
wrote, on the bottom,
and it makes no claims on you.
[ Laughter ]
I, myself, do not have this gift
but I'm the beneficiary
of poetry.
And I'm the beneficiary
of the written word.
And what I thought I'd do
just for a few minutes to try
to illustrate what the
written word does for us.
And so I have a home
ten blocks from here.
And I have a collection
in that home.
And some people collect stamps.
I collect accounts of
different emotions.
And so I collect
accounts of joy.
And so for example, and when
you have all these accounts,
you realize it comes in layers.
There's physical joy that gets,
when people are moving together,
my old history professor
was named Julio McNeal.
And he was in bootcamp, and
he was marching with his men
and he experienced
a moment of joy.
He wrote, "Words are inadequate
to describe the emotion aroused
by the prolonged movement in
unison that drilling involved.
A sense of pervasive
well-being is what I recall.
More specifically, a strange
sense of personal enlargement.
A sort of swelling up.
Becoming bigger than life,
thanks to participation
in a collective ritual."
And so that's one layer of joy.
Another is what they call
collective effervescence.
Every group of humanity dances
in rhythm when they're joyful.
And so Zadie Smith was in
London in a nightclub in 1999,
and she heard Q-Tip
rapping over the music.
And she describes this moment.
"A real thin man with enormous
eyes reached across the sea
of bodies for my hand.
He kept asking me the
same thing over and over.
You feeling it?
I was. My -- my ridiculous
heels were killing me.
I was terrified I might die.
Yet I felt simultaneously
overwhelmed with delight
that can I kick it should
happen to be playing
at this precise moment in
the history of the world.
And was now morphing
into smells Latin spirit.
I took the man's hand, the top
of my head flew away, we danced
and danced, we gave
ourselves up to joy."
That's another layer.
Then there might be what
you call emotional joy.
One of my heroes in life is
a woman named Dorothy Day.
And she was -- got pregnant
and she realized that most
of the accounts of childbirth
she'd ever read were written
by men.
So 45 minutes after giving
birth she wrote an account,
a very beautiful account.
And it ends with
a moment of joy.
She writes, "If I had
written the greatest book,
composed the greatest symphony,
or carved the most exquisite
figure I could not have felt a
more exalted creator than I did
when they placed my
child in my arms.
No human creature could receive
or contain so vast a flood
of love and joy as I felt
after the birth of my child.
And with this came the need
to worship and to adore."
And when you see these moments,
you realize that joy happens
when the skin barrier
between one person
and another disappears.
Joy often involves
a loss of self.
David White who's a
-- a good poet writes,
"Joy is a meeting place
of deep intentionality
and self-forgetting.
The bodily alchemy of
what lies inside us
in communion would have
but formerly seemed
outside, but now is neither.
Dance, laughter, affection,
skin touching skin,
singing in the car, music in the
kitchen, the quite irreplaceable
and companionable
presence of a daughter.
The sheer intoxicating beauty
of the world that inhabited us
as an edge between what we
previously thought was us,
and what was not us."
Then there's a couple
higher levels.
I'll just two more.
And one is transcendent joy.
When we think we're
reaching across some barrier
that we can't really explain.
So I am not a poet.
I have a friend whose
an actual poet.
And his name is Christian
Wyman, a very beautiful poet.
And wherever -- when
you talk to Chris,
he's lived in a lot of cities.
And he always lived there
because there was a woman there.
So like, he lived in Buffalo.
Why'd you live in Buffalo?
Oh I had a girlfriend there.
And then where, you know,
why'd you live in Rochester?
Oh a girlfriend there.
And so he lived in Progue.
He had a girlfriend there.
And so one night he was
working on this poetry,
or one morning, in the kitchen.
And he was just at
the kitchen table.
And a falcon landed on the
windowsill across the window.
And it scanned out and
it didn't seem him.
It just was scanning, like
two feet away from him.
And his girlfriend
was taking a shower.
So he went and got her and said
come out you got to see this.
So she came out dripping, naked.
And they're standing there just
with this falcon right there.
And the falcon turns and
looks eyes with Wyman.
And his girlfriend said,
wish for something.
Take this moment,
And he later wrote
about a poem --
he wrote a poem about
the experience,
and it includes this stanza.
"And for a long moment I'm
still in, I wished and wished
and wished and wished that
the moment would not end.
And just like that it vanished."
So that's that content that
people have with nature.
And then finally the --
the part I'll end with,
and I actually don't
have a passage with this.
Is some people -- some moments
of joy are just transcendent,
but moments, and then they
go away, like Wyman's.
But some people for
them, joy is not a --
an experience it's an outlook.
It's something they bring
into the world every day.
And it comes from the habitual
giving other people's delight.
And it becomes their permanent
way of being in the world.
I was at a luncheon
here a couple years ago,
and I was seated next
to the Dahlia Lama.
And the guy laughs for
no apparent reason.
He just starts laughing.
And you're sitting there,
and you want to be polite,
so you laugh, and then
he laughs, and you laugh.
And I had nothing
to say to the guy,
because he was just so happy.
And so I finally said -- he
had a canvas Dahlia Lama bag,
so I said, you got
any candy in your bag?
And so he starts pulling
out the stuff in the bag.
It turns out to be everything
you get in the First-Class cabin
of an international flight,
like a little razor, ear plugs.
But he just radiates joy.
And Kathy and I have a friend,
a very famous guy, Yo-Yo Ma.
That guy just radiates joy.
And that to me is a
higher form of life
because they are just delight
in things, delight in gratitude
and they offer goodness.
Now so why have I
run through all this?
It seems to me we're born
with relatively primitive
understandings
of our own emotions,
at least men are.
[ Laughter ]
But what language, and
especially poetry does,
is it educates us
in our own emotions.
When you've read a poem, you
haven't gotten new knowledge,
or new information, but
you've had a new experience.
And oft it's -- it's an
emotional experience.
And you widen your
repertoire of emotions.
The greatest poet of our day,
Taylor Swift, was once asked,
I actually sort of mean that.
Was once asked, you
write all about sadness.
She says, there are actually
22 different kinds of sadness.
There's your dog leaves sadness,
your boyfriend dumps you,
your mom -- and she played a
different tune for all kinds.
She's an expert on sadness.
And so it's like we're born
with one piano key for joy.
But through poetry and
through language we learn,
well there are actually
88 different piano keys.
And who would want to live
with the simplistic notion
of our own emotions when you
can live with an enriched one.
It's the sort of thing that
just makes life so much better.
And then finally, if you
realize joy is the kind of thing
that the Dahlia Lama or Yo-Yo
Ma could experience and project,
why would you want to live
for just mere happiness
when you could have joy?
And when you make that kind
of realization your whole
life can turn around.
And so that's what I think
you guys are offering, the --
the explication of
your own emotions
and giving everybody a sense of
what you've learned about them.
And so I congratulate you,
I thank you for what
you're about to do.
And as I mentioned, one
serious note, this is a moment
where our nation needs
a story, and it needs
to be told through poetry.
And so I ask that you spend some
time at this next year filling
in what is a gap and that if
there's anything that's going
to unite such a diverse
country it's going to be poetry
and story and narrative.
And I'm -- I'm sure you're
going to play a role in that.
So I have never experienced
the kind
of joy that Sadie Smith did.
I can't dance to Q-Tip.
But I have had a couple
of experiences of joy
and this is a replication of
one of my earlier experiences.
Twice in my life I've
had this experience.
Introducing Valerie June.
[ Laughter ]
And this is my second.
And this is joy personified.
Valerie.
[ Applause ]
>> Valerie June: Well
I have the pleasure
of spending some personal
time with the students.
And I was asking each one
of them about their voices.
And I'm a musician but also a
songwriter, and a poet as well.
So the voice of the poet is
really an interesting thing
to me.
And one thing they told me,
each one in their different way,
of how they hear the voice
of a poem is it usually
starts with one line.
And I'll hear that line, and
I'll work with that line again
and again for a little bit.
And then I'll start
writing the poem.
And the poems comes really fast
once they hear that one line.
And they sit with it, then the
poem writing is fast after that.
So I hope that you
go to your regions
and you take those one lines,
and you inspire everyone
in your region.
And I know that you
have this power.
I know you have the
power to do that.
And it only takes but one line.
I'm going to play a song
for you on my little baby,
it's a song for love
and for healing.
And it's called Somebody
to Love.
[ Music ]
Well if you're tired and
you're feeling so lonely,
you wake up at night
and you thinking
that only if you had somebody.
Would I be somebody?
Somebody to love.
Did they tell you there were
plenty of fish in the sea,
but you're out in the cold
and you're feeling empty,
are you looking for somebody.
Would I be somebody?
Somebody to love.
Would I be somebody, would I
be somebody, I be somebody.
Would I be somebody,
would I be somebody,
somebody to love.
Are you watching the moon
rise in the darkness of night,
and battered and broken
because you know it ain't right?
You ain't got nobody.
Would I be somebody.
Somebody to love.
Would I be somebody, I would
be somebody, I be somebody.
Would I be somebody, I be
somebody, I be somebody,
would I be somebody,
I be somebody,
I be some body, somebody
to love.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
She's a sweet baby.
So I'd like to invite the
poets to the stage now.
And Dr. Matthew as well.
[ Applause ]
And representing the Midwest
is Darious Atefat-Peckham.
And representing the
Southeast is Daniel Blokh.
Northeast is Alexandra
Contreras-Montesano, let me
know I know I messed that up.
And representing the Southwest
is Heather Laurel Jensen.
And representing the
West is Ariana Smith.
[ Applause ]
I believe they're each
going to read something.
>> Darius Atefat-Peckham:
Thank you all for coming.
I'm the National Student Poet
representing the Midwest.
I'm Darius Atefat-Peckham.
I'm from Huntington, West
Virginia, and I go to school
at Interlochen Arts Academy.
This poem's called, the
Beautiful Day Dance.
For my father, widower at 33.
Mornings when I woke up
my face sagging, defeated,
dad would smile at me and
wave his arms above his head.
His legs kicking beneath him.
A desperate flail,
but a chance to show
that he could move his
body aw well as anyone.
When the sunlight
seemed to break and spill
down his raised chin like
egg whites, and the chill bit
into us both, he'd sing.
The song isn't as
important to me now
as the beauty of the dance.
And I'm sure the melody
was a repetitious rip off
of zip-a-dee-doo-dah,
though sometimes we tilted
our heads beneath the sky
and just yelled it.
Despite the neighbors.
Dispelling puffs of
warm air from our mouths
as we screamed, it's
a beautiful day.
To the blue that filled the
space behind the clouds.
To whoever was listening.
To the way I sweat at nights.
Dad rubbing the wet t-shirt that
clung to my back whispering,
it's all right, we're OK,
over and over like a chorus.
To the broken limbs
and the deaths
that rendered us for a time.
Living memories.
Regretfully alive.
But thankful that we could
always spin ourselves around,
arms spread wide,
to live and dance
and to sing anyways,
to sing always.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Daniel Blokh: Shalom y'all.
I'm Daniel Blokh.
And I'm the Southeast
National Student Poet,
if you wouldn't tell
from the all.
I'm from Birmingham, Alabama
and my poem is called Sixty.
Like his own father before him,
at 3:00 a.m. my father wakes,
wanders the house a little,
pours his cereal,
no eggs, no bacon.
My father doesn't touch meat.
Lives softly enough to enter
and leave the world a shadow,
a breeze on doorsteps.
He reads the news until I wake.
On the way to school he'll talk
about the latest friend
I didn't get to meet.
This one was only 52 and
lived back in Kharkov.
Each night they fleshed
their throats
out let evening make
meat of them.
It took years to
learn the way a body
like a hurt dog holds its
history and tight jaws.
My father shouts
at the car swerving
in its lane ahead of us.
Then asks, have you
reconsidered being vegetarian?
I say, maybe.
Which we both know
means, I don't want to go
to the trouble of saying no.
And we've pulled
up to the school.
He hasn't had a chance
to talk about the news
or say how proud he was to
watch another morning swell
up through the cracks of night.
I haven't had a chance to
wish him happy birthday,
and anyway what is there
to say but good bye my son
and good-bye father
who is my son.
Whose eyes I carry into
any rearview mirror.
Any 3:00 a.m. drive home
when one car sideswipes
another behind me.
My father, who knows we
live in worlds of wheels,
all trying to catch us.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Alexandra
Contreras-Montesano: Hello,
my name is Alexandra
Contreras-Montesano.
And I am representing
the Northeast.
I'm from Burlington, Vermont,
and I go to Burlington
High School.
This is Puebla.
Puebla is chocolate
dipped, syrupy as I spoon it
out of the close-knit town
surrounding Mexico City.
I just want to gulp it down,
suck the marrow from the cattle
that get leaner every year.
It smells good, being home,
or being in a place
that was once home.
I can't help but hold my
breath, abducting it in my lungs
because the wind here
is a different flavor
than the wind there.
I thought the thing I missed
most was the sizzle your bare
feet make against the packed
dirt of the evening road,
but I was wrong because
I am intoxicated
by the way my grandmother
clasps her hands to my heart.
Like I never left.
Puebla tastes salty, as I
like it from my top lip,
brushing it from the
corners of my eyes,
letting it fall,
absorb into my skin.
I know I can't come back until
the next thunderstorm season.
It gets easier to come
and harder to leave.
I wish I could stay in this
town where everything tastes
like cayenne mixed with just
the right amount of lime.
It burns but you
laugh until the sour.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Heather Laurel Jensen: Howdy.
I'm Heather Laurel Jensen.
I'm from Mesa, Arizona.
I'll be representing
the Southwest.
This is Allergy Apologizing
in Hindsight.
I hear July will bring
the coming monsoon season
and a stock market crash.
Each light on the water tower
will blink and then strobe.
A cougar will sleep under
my trampoline for weeks.
Dogs will break into
every antique shop
and devour fine china.
From there the moon will
roll across the cliff
and crush the nearest
mobile home.
Today they are dredging my best
friend's body from the lake.
She is wrapped in pink tarp, and
identifiable by her pony tail.
The edges of each day
are okra and pulling
up by the corners like linoleum.
Occasionally when I take a
shower there is vomit already
in the bathtub.
I should not be here.
Not like this.
Three weeks ago we were kneeling
at the gulf of a psych ward
with my hands pressing and
ziplocked to her nose and mouth
in lieu of a paper bag.
In hindsight, I am not even an
effective attempt at a solution.
A threat is still a threat so
when you pretend it's benign.
Sorrow is still sorrow
with my headphones in.
Her grief was still
grief when I avoided it.
In the future I hope to be
unafraid of asking questions.
Her parents will join a nunnery.
The lake will drain through
a metal slit in the earth.
Her old things will appear
on every subway in the world.
In hindsight, I will
look for the cliff crumbs
in the cuffs of her jeans.
In hindsight, I will call the
hospital and tell them her name.
[ Applause ]
>> Ariana Smith: Hey.
OK. My name is Ariana Smith.
I am from Las Vegas, Nevada,
and I will be representing
the West region.
This poem is entitled
Descendant.
Grandfather, birthed from
burning crosses in dense
and sticky Georgia, smoke
clinging to black skin
like fresh cotton
to nimble fingers.
Breathing in freedom
with zephyr.
Sunday shoes stuck
in rich wet moss.
Grandmother, blooming
out of rose milk week
from the Carolinas,
twig like brown legs,
skipping across sweeping
willows.
Her clouds were frothy
and pastel.
Pearlescent velvet swaying
like tiny dancers above her.
Father, product of an
exodus from South to North,
the other side of the sunshine.
My father, a lingering love,
weaved from ancestral
needle and thread.
Blood line like a river, flowing
through state line Mississippi
currents of dripping peach vine.
I descend from the other
side of the train tracks,
resembling country
border from suctioned lips
to rattling jazz
trumpet measures,
from hot buttery biscuits
on the kitchen stove.
From mommas and aunties
with kaleidoscopes for eyes
and the Freedom Riders
Bus set aflame in a city
that was already burning.
An eternity of southern
acrimony, a forbidden home,
familiar, familial,
a fresh wound
that never seems to scab over.
There lay heritage,
blood, spirit, bone.
Generations gone with the
wind, surviving through me,
my heart strung to
theirs like DNA.
Their flesh dissolving
like sugar cube,
my body still on stolen land.
Someday we will all
taste liberation
on the tips of our tongues.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Katheryn Matthew:
Well I think we have two
poets from last year here.
Can you raise your hands?
Yeah. Great.
Congratulations.
Thank you for coming.
[ Applause ]
So I think we're going to have
reflections from Anne Castillo?
Right? Great.
And Ben is here to add, you
know, counterpoint, I'm sure.
[ Laughter ]
>> Annie Castillo: Hi everyone
and thanks for having me back.
Welcome to the appointment
of this year's National
Student Poets.
I want to congratulate the
Class of 2018, Darius, Alex,
Heather, Daniel and Ariana.
And to your parents, teachers,
friends and supporters.
Thank you for guiding
these people who write
and envision change
in their community.
I wanted to offer a quick
recap of our year as the Class
of 2017, along side Juliette,
Kensal, Ben and Camilla,
I've had the best
year of my life.
For starters, I made
four lifelong friends.
Better yet, we skipped
school to travel together.
[ Laughter ]
To New York City in October,
the Aspen Ideas Festival
and Carnegie Hall in June.
We were certainly the recipients
of a lot of generosity.
People like Juan Felipe
Herrera, Dr. Katheryn Matthew,
Dr. Carla Hayden, Sarah Jessica
Parker, Elizabeth Alexander,
and Edward Hirsh lent us their
time and wisdom unreservedly.
Thanks to the hard work of
the staff at the Alliance
for Young Artists and Writers,
we've experienced affirmation
and received a platform to
share poetry with our peers.
We were given the
space to write bravely
and delve deeply into poetry.
But this year isn't about the
amazing gift each national
student poet here
has been given.
Don't get me wrong.
We should say thank you
often and sincerely.
After all, this program
is the culmination
of many wonderful people's
vision and hard work.
To Virginia, Hannah, Deborah,
Olivia and all the others
who helped at the Alliance
and IMLS, we thank you
from the bottom of our hearts.
In eighth grade, my English
teacher asked our class
to write essays not about
the best gift we got
over winter break, but instead
about the best gift we gave.
It shifted our perspectives to
generosity and thoughtfulness.
And it was a lesson
that stayed with me.
I share this with you because
at its heart this is the magic
of the National Student
Poet's Program.
They help us and we turn
around to help others.
I know the Class of 2018 will
change their communities,
amplify the voices too
often left unheard.
Make more room at the table
for new and bright poets.
I know this because each of
you is an astounding writer
and ambassador to your craft.
I also know this because
I've seen the same generosity
in my friends, Ben, Kensal,
Juliette and Camilla this year.
Camilla spent time helping
teach poetry therapy
to immigrant advocates and
attorneys and connected
with refugees from
Somalia and the Congo.
Juliette collaborated
with doctors and patients,
using language to heal
emotional trauma in hospitals.
Kensal spent time
with Native students
at the Sherman Indian Boarding
School discussing identity
and the notion of home
and published a collection
of their writings.
Ben was poet and resident
for summer school,
giving academic enrichment
to local Minneapolis
middle schoolers.
They've all accomplished
wonderful things
and I hope you'll take
inspiration and guidance
from them as you search
for your own path forward.
Before we go, we of the
Class of 2017 wanted
to give a few pieces of advice.
Juliette says you should learn
from everyone you
meet, and I agree.
Ben urges you to be unafraid
to seize the opportunity
you worked so hard for.
We also recommend you
wear powder foundation
in TV interviews.
[ Laughter ]
And send thank you notes early.
Above all though, take a
lesson from Juan Felipe Herrera
who spent the last 15 minute
of our master class together,
showing us how to
fold Starbucks bags
into makeshift poetry booklets.
Looking back, I realize
he was showing us how
to make room for poetry.
And above all, remember you're
here because you earned it,
and we need your voices
now more than ever.
We're standing right beside
you, and we can't wait
to see what you'll do.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: Well
could we have another round
of applause for this
fabulous poets?
Please.
[ Applause ]
You guys can clap
for yourselves.
[ Applause ]
I'm Anya Creightney.
I'm the Programs Manager at the
Poetry and Literature Center
and the task falls
on me to close
out these beautiful festivities.
But before I do, I want to
see if we can play this video.
I'm told that we
may have some luck.
So poetry keeps up pliable,
so we'll -- we'll try again.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see what I can do.
See how magic I can be.
[ Music ]
>> My Name is Tracy K.
Smith, and I'm delighted
to congratulate you on having
been selected this year's
National Student Poets.
It speaks to the commitment
that you've already demonstrated
to poetry as an art form,
and as a way of life.
As I see it, poems teach us new
ways of looking at the world.
They give us new terms for
describing the many active
and powerful feelings
that we live with.
And they also allow
us to listen closely
to other people's
voices and their stories.
I think all of that is
indispensable to a full life.
And I'm thrilled that over the
next year you will be able to go
into your communities, doing
this with other people,
talking about why
poetry matters to you.
That's what I've been doing over
the last year as Poet Laureate
and it's been one of the most
rewarding acts of my life
as an artist, and a person
to go into communities
with people I don't know,
people I may never see again,
and feel like we actually have
something meaningful to say
to one another through
the vehicle of poetry.
I'm sorry I'm not there with
you tonight, I'm actually
in Alaska talking
poetry with new friends.
But I'm excited to
join you tomorrow
and celebrate your
accomplishments.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Anya Creightney: Thanks
for your patience all.
I'm glad you guys got to
hear her special words.
So before I close things out, I
just want to thank our partners,
The Alliance for Young Artists
and Writers and the Institute
for Museum and Library Services.
I'd also like to thank our
special guests, David Brooks,
for that rousing, that was
very sweet, emotional talk.
And also Valerie June, I'd
like to thank her as well.
So before I send you
off to celebrate,
I just want to remind you all
that the National Book
Festival is this weekend
and the student poets
will be performing
at the book festival
not once, but twice,
on the expo of floors.
So come make sure
to check them out.
And also the full day is
lots of fabulous programming.
So make sure you --
you check that out.
Very last thing there are
surveys on your chairs.
If you wouldn't be so
kind as to fill them out,
it does help us here
at the library.
So that's all.
Please go out, enjoy,
congratulate our poems,
our poets, and please
have some food outside.
Thanks everyone.
[ Applause ]